[Musique]
c'est à mascara jardin botanique que se
sont retrouvés les conseillers
départementaux jeunes de la réunion et
la délégation de l'anacej venus
spécialement sur notre île pour célébrer
les 30 ans du cdj autour de différents
ateliers ils vont échanger sur des
thématiques comme la mobilité la
citoyenneté l'égalité des chances la
transition écologique et la solidarité
non non de solidarité sens bien plus
basse que celle des rayons et à ce très
intéressant de voir sa différence cet
écart qu'on a encore en tant qu' en tant
que jeunes comme vous tous j'ai peur en
fait de ce que lorsqu'on nous réserve
c'est à dire qu'on veut faire entendre
une voix
c'est pour ça qu'on craint des instances
comme celle ci mais finalement est-ce
que c'est bien d'être seulement entendu
ou est-ce que seulement derrière il faut
agir partager des cultures différentes
échanger des idées ses conseillers porte
la vision d'une société dans laquelle
ils sont acteurs de leur engagement
on va dans la pérennisation de cette et
de ce comics procéder par le mental de
jeunes le département est très fier de
ce projet qui portait de cuillé 30 ans
la vision des jeunes aujourd'hui doit ce
nous être associés aussi parce qu'on a
trop souvent nous à se dire adultes
nous savons non peut-être que nous nous
oublions trop souvent cette vision
jeunes qui est pour moi entre les
tailles un appui sur cette journée de
travail donnera lieu à une restitution
de tous ces ateliers dès le lendemain à
la villa du département
[Musique]